[Music]
good evening and here are the nominees
for best original song we really did not
expect to win it was sort of like
finding
i mean just being nominated was like
finding twenty dollars in your pocket it
was very nice and very surprising when
they called our name when when lynn said
mexico
mexico christian anderson lopez and
robert lopez for remember me
the first thing i thought is i gotta hug
the kids i'm so glad they're here to see
that it was really special to have them
there and to be able to shout out to
them and our daughters katie and annie
who are here with us tonight
your love
and creativity inspire everything we do
we wrote remember me
um because we're songwriters who have to
leave our kids behind and we leave them
little songs that they can sing so i
sing a secret song to you each night we
are apart i sing a secret song to you
each night we are apart
remember me
we left them with lullaby so they could
feel our presence
and so i think there wouldn't be the
same remember me without those two girls
you know it's crazy that song um writing
remember me very shortly after we wrote
it my grandmother passed away and then
um sadly a few years later my mom
uh lost battle with cancer and um that
song
helped me uh
realize that it's through our memories
that our loved ones live on and there's
feeling of a family reunion to coco a
family reunion that can cross the life
and death barrier that is a really
really beautiful thought and i think
that's why people love the movie so much
this is for my mom who passed away
everyone who knew her will always
remember her
[Applause]
you